connor is with us in youngstown ohio
good afternoon connor how can
ken and i help hi um
so i'm 19 years old and newly married
um i was never really afforded the
opportunity to go to college based on my
circumstances
um and i just i needed to support myself
and be able to pay rent
after high school um
so well while i was in high school i got
a trade school degree
and currently i'm working as a machinist
um
so i just just recently got married
and i got myself in a little bit of a
mess during covid
um but i'm working on i'm on baby step
number two i have two credit cards paid
off and just uh
i'm married some student loan debt but
so i i have to pay that down and then
i have a personal loan that i have to
take care of
but other than that everything's going
well getting the debt pit down pretty
quickly
ultimately i was just wondering since i
have to work full time
and i have another mouth to feed now
i i was just debating on whether or not
college would be worth it
because i mean i i wasn't able to go out
of high school but
um and i know
you guys teach the student loan debt
isn't a good idea obviously
so um what do you want to do you're 19.
so you're really young
but you've already been in the trades
long enough to get a good sense of what
that's like
what do you want to do well i worked i
mean i worked in a machine shop through
high school too
part time so i mean this is about my
fourth year doing it
um i'm making almost 45 000 a year good
i usually go over with overtime
good right so i mean we make ends meet
just fine
uh cost of living what do you mean what
do you want to do
you're 19. what do you allow yourself to
dream about when you're stuck at the
stoplight
or you're mowing the grass or you're
working on what do you want to do when
you're 39 49 what do you want to do
successful picture yourself what are you
doing
i want to own my own shop someday so
you're doing the work
you're doing the work you're getting
paid
connor you're getting paid by somebody
else
to learn how to run a shop so while
you're
doing one roll you your head needs to be
on a swivel and i'm guessing it already
is you sound like a really mature 19
year old
but you're you're just paying attention
to everything you can pay attention to
and then
if you're in a good relationship with
your leader right now eventually you're
taking him or her lunch whoever's
running the shop over there and you're
saying hey
uh how do you do the books how do you
pay how do you save money on parts
you're learning everything you can
because one of these days you're going
to do it for yourself
so do you need to go to college i'm
going to flip the question on you
do you need to go to college to
eventually
become an entrepreneur
owner of your own shop business do you
well i mean i suppose i wouldn't i mean
i i would like
i've definitely thought about getting my
mechanical engineering degree because i
love mechanical systems and design and
just figuring out how things work
how would that help you achieve your
dream you tell me
ultimately i mean for for customer
service based as far as
designing re-engineering different parts
and things that they need made
i mean most machine shops hire an
engineer okay but i mean
ultimately it comes down to whether i
want to shoot shoot for the stars and
just
bet on me doing that or going to college
sort of a safer route to
just make a higher income as an employee
wait a second
wait a second so you know this is this
is ao i'm getting all fired up
you have been taught connor the culture
has taught you that going to college is
a safer route
let me remind you you're already in the
industry
all you got to do is keep doing a good
job and acquire some skills in the
actual shop and you can keep moving up
is that true or false and i don't mind
if i'm wrong tell me if i'm wrong
i'd say it's true absolutely it's true
so so again your income is based on your
output not the degree
am i right or am i wrong in this
particular business
so if you want to go get a mechanical
engineering degree
just because you want to have it great
but wait until you and your
bride pay off that debt and you save up
money and my friend here could take over
and tell you how to do
do the degree debt free he'll give you
his book i'm just volunteering you to
give this young man in the book
but here's the point connor that's up to
you
but i'm answering your question do you
need to go to college
i don't think so i think you answered it
yeah uh do you want to
if you want to great but you better cash
flow it ao yeah i mean i agree with you
ken i really don't even want to talk
about college
i think that i think connor what you
need to do is just
focus on your sweet spot like what you
and ken just talked about
uh and maybe go to trade school so you
can learn some particular stuff around
that
uh but i would not go to college man i
mean i can i can give you a copy of my
book
no i'm not gonna give you a copy of my
book what i want you to do is connect
with ken i want you to listen to his
show
um and i really want you to learn more
and more and more about his content
because i think your path is different
and there's nothing wrong with your path
being different yeah and i think you
just have to accept that
uh making forty five thousand dollars
right now if i'm not mistaken that's
that's what he said right yeah the
average
single person is making forty eight
thousand so you're only three thousand
dollars less than the average
person in america right now so you're
doing very well yes
and you and your wife double income pay
off the debt
walk out the baby steps pay off the debt
get the three to six months expenses in
the bank
start saving 15 of your income towards
retirement you guys are going to be net
worth millionaires starting as early as
you are
and then listen you're being trained
you're being paid right now
to learn how to run the business you
eventually want to run absolutely
absolutely